So this is it
It's all been leading up to this
Ready?
Let's go!
There was an idea (Nick Fury)
To bring together a group of remarkable people (Tony)
To see if we could become something more (Vision)
So when they needed us (Thor)
We could fight the battles (Thor)
That they never could (Black Widow)
*avenger theme plays in the background*
In time (Thanos)
You will know what its like to lose (Thanos)
To feel so desperately that you're right,
Then to fail all the same (Thanos)
Dread it (Thanos)
Run from it (Thanos)
Destiny still arrives (Thanos)
Evacuate the city (Black panther)
Engage all defences (Black panther)
And get this man a shield (Black panther)
Fun isn't something one considers,  when balancing the universe (Thanos)
But this *laughs*, does put a smile on my face (Thanos)
Who the hell are you guys? (Thor)